كان قتل الهوكي الألماني
جريمة فظيعة لم يكن من المفترض أن تحدث
أبدًا ، وبالطبع كان لـ Ben
تأثير عميق للغاية علينا جميعًا
السعوديين وقد قلنا
بوضوح أننا نتحمل
مسؤولية محاسبة المسؤولين عن
وجود محاكمات.  وأولئك المتورطين بشكل غير مباشر
في القتل قد تمت
إدانتهم ، والأهم من ذلك أننا
عملنا بجد لإجراء الإصلاحات اللازمة
في أجهزتنا الأمنية
لضمان عدم حدوث شيء
كهذا مرة أخرى ، وقد قاده
ولي العهد على وجه التحديد إلى  تأكد من أن
لدينا الضمانات المعمول بها وهذا
شيء من هذا القبيل ، ما لن يحدث
مرة أخرى ،
فهناك العديد من أصدقاء المملكة
العربية السعودية الذين سينظرون في عملية محاكمة
Jamarcus Russia ويقولون
إنها في الحقيقة لا تتمتع بالشفافية
التي  كانوا يتوقعون أن يروا
لمنحهم الثقة في أن
تطلعات المملكة هذه للتأكد من
أن هذا لن يحدث مرة أخرى أبدًا.
ncy غير موجود
لماذا مكان المحاكمة الآن ولماذا
لا لماذا لا توجد هذه
الشفافية هناك مستوى من
الشفافية اعتقدنا أنه
ضروري
، سُمح للأعضاء الخمسة الدائمين في الأمم المتحدة
بحضور  قضية قضائية بالطبع
والأهم من ذلك
أنه تم السماح لأسرة جمال كيشافجي بحضور
المحاكمة وهذا حق أساسي في
النظام القضائي السعودي.
هؤلاء
المتهمون قد أدينوا ،
فلهم بالطبع الحق في الاستئناف
وستمضي هذه الاستئنافات كما هو
معتاد في النظام القضائي السعودي.
لقد دعمنا دائمًا كل
الجهود الحقيقية نحو الدفع باتجاه اتفاق سلام
بين الفلسطينيين
والإسرائيليين الذين دعمناهم العربي.
مبادرة السلام التي دعت إلى
تسوية القضية
وسنواصل دعم كل
الجهود الحقيقية نحو تسوية عادلة
لها  مهم جدا بالنسبة لنا بالطبع
أن يتم حل هذه القضية ولكن يجب أن
يكون في سياق حصول الفلسطينيين
على جميع حقوقهم
وسندعم أي جهود تعمل لتحقيق
هذه الغاية ويعلن الرئيس ترامب
أن القدس يجب أن تكون عاصمة
لإسرائيل.  السفارة هناك ، ما هو
تأثير ذلك على
إمكانية الحصول على نتيجة إيجابية من
هذه الصفقة ، أعتقد في النهاية أنه من
المهم أن نعرب بالطبع عن
رأينا حول هذه الخطوة علنًا
أنها ليست مفيدة ولكن الشيء المهم
هو أننا نحاول  والعثور على المجالات
التي يوجد فيها اتفاق والبناء
عليها والعمل نحو تسوية
يمكن أن تستوعب حقوق
الفلسطينيين وتضمن سلامًا طويل الأمد ،
ما هي المناطق التي يمكن أن تقول إنها
نوع من تلك المجالات
ذات الاهتمام المشترك وأعتقد أن هناك  اتفاق واسع على
أنه يجب أن يكون هناك
حل الدولتين على حدود عام 1964
وأنك تعرف المحلفين الذين
تحتاجهم قضية القدس  أن يتم تسويتها
بطريقة تضمن حقوق جميع
الشعوب ، وسنعمل من أجل
دفع ذلك إلى الأمام ،
وقد أعلنت الحكومة الإسرائيلية مؤخرًا أنه
يمكن للمواطنين الإسرائيليين زيارة المملكة العربية السعودية
للسياحة وللأعمال ، فهذه
بداية لعلاقة جديدة كيف
المهم هو معرفة ما إذا كان ذلك يؤثر على
أي شيء لأن سياستنا تظل
كما هي ، ليس لدينا علاقات مع
دولة إسرائيل ولا يمكن لحاملي جوازات السفر الإسرائيلية
في هذا الوقت زيارة
المملكة من وجهة النظر الإسرائيلية ،
فهم يفتحون بابًا ولكن إلى جانبهم
الباب ليس مفتوحًا من جانبك هو
أنه سيتغير في أي وقت قريب ، فنحن
ندعم بشدة الحل السلمي
للصراع ، وبمجرد
التوصل إلى اتفاق سلام بين الفلسطينيين
والإسرائيليين ، أعتقد أن دمج
إسرائيل في السياق الإقليمي يعد أمرًا بالغ الأهمية.
الكثير
مطروح على الطاولة وبالطبع سوف نصلي
لأنك تعلم في اقتراحنا
لمعاهدة السلام العربية أنه تم تضمينه في هذا
التطبيع الكامل  فيما يتعلق بدولة
إسرائيل بمجرد تحقيق السلام ، يعتبر
حفتر جزءًا من الحل إذا
سمح له بالسيطرة على العاصمة
طرابلس ، فنحن نؤيد الدعوة إلى
وقف إطلاق النار وإيجاد طريق سياسي
للمضي قدمًا ، لقد أيدنا اتفاق هرات
الذي تم وضعه.  هيكل الحكم الحالي
الذي
كان له بعد فيه دور أيضًا
للحكومة في طرابلس ، أعتقد أنه من
المهم أن
تواصل الأطراف الليبية الحديث وتواصل العمل من
أجل إيجاد حل سياسي ،
نحن بالطبع قلقون بشأن
استمرار إراقة الدماء و  لذلك
لدينا علم بأننا ندعو جميع الأطراف
للالتزام بوقف إطلاق النار والعمل من
أجل حل سياسي وانخراط الديوك الرومية
الرغبة في إرسال
قوات إلى ليبيا هو أن هذا جزء من
الحل هذا بالتأكيد ليس جزءًا
من الحل ، إنه أمر مهم.
مساهم في عدم الاستقرار خاصة
أننا رأينا الآن أن
تركيا لم ترسل مستشارين فقط ولكننا
سمعنا وكان لدينا معلومات  معلومات استخباراتية عن
نقل المقاتلين السوريين من سوريا إلى ليبيا من
قبل تركيا وهذا أمر خطير للغاية
لأن هذا يضيف مقاتلين غير منظمين
إلى ساحة معركة
معقدة للغاية بالفعل وتخاطر بإدخال
عناصر متطرفة وقضايا أخرى في
الصراع الليبي يجب
منعها حقًا.  قلقون بشأن
ما تفعله تركيا في ليبيا وهو
أمر يجب أن
نشعر بالقلق الشديد بشأنه ، هل أخبرتك الولايات المتحدة
أنها ستقتل قاسم
سليماني ، لم نكن على علم بهذه
العمليات الآن ، وما هو تأثير
ذلك على علاقتك  مع
الولايات المتحدة بالنظر إلى أن هذا بطريقة ما
أوصل المنطقة إلى
حافة الحرب ، خاصة عندما ترد إيران
إذا قُتلت القوات الأمريكية ، كان من
الممكن أن يكون هناك تصعيد حقيقي للولايات
المتحدة  الذين تصرفوا دفاعًا عن النفس
، تعرضوا للهجوم في
العراق وفقًا لما قيل لنا من
معلومات استخبارية مهمة بأن قاسم
سليماني كان يعمل على
هجمات إضافية على المصالح الأمريكية ، نعلم أن
قاسم سليماني لديه سجل دموي للغاية
في المنطقة  لهجمات متعددة
وتنظيم مقدمة
لشبكات الميليشيات الإيرانية وجميع
شبكاتها التي تعمل بالوكالة للهجوم بأعمال إرهابية مستمرة ،
لذلك نعتقد أن
الأمريكيين كانوا يتصرفون في
دفاعهم المشروع عن النفس ،
كما طالبنا بالطبع
بوقف التصعيد بعد ذلك  وأعتقد أننا
نرى في المنطقة أن الأمور
قد هدأت نسبيًا وسنواصل
العمل مع جميع الأطراف لمنع أي
مزيد من التصعيد في المستقبل ،
وقد قال الرئيس ترامب إن هذه
الضربة ضد سليماني جعلت
المنطقة أكثر أمانًا وأن المنطقة أكثر أمانًا.  في
الوقت الحالي ، أعتقد أن المنطقة
أصبحت أكثر أمانًا بعد إخراج قاسم سليماني
من المشهد ، لكن لدينا جميعًا
مسؤولية  ذ لمواصلة العمل
للتأكد من أننا نمنع أي مزيد من
التصعيد وأننا نضع المنطقة على
المسار الصحيح نحو المزيد من الاستقرار المزيد من
الأمن المزيد من التنمية المزيد من
الاستثمار بدلاً من العنف
والإرهاب والأنشطة التي
تواصل إيران دفعها في المنطقة
أعرفك  التطلعات إلى ما تريد
منهم أن يفعلوه والرسالة التي
لديك ولكن هي أي شيء ملموس
يمكنك القول أنه قد تغيروا
حتى الآن ولم نر أي
علامات حقيقية لتغيير السلوك في هذه
المرحلة.  ليسوا إيجابيين
لكننا سنواصل دعوتهم إلى
التصرف بطريقة تدعم
الاستقرار الإقليمي